hey pascal
kennst du den unterschied
zwischen nicht und kein
hey pascal
kennst du den unterschied
zwischen nicht und kein
ja ich glaube schon
lasst uns ein bisschen üben
so werden wir es sicher besser verstehen
hast du hunger
ja ich habe hunger
ja
ich habe hunger nein
ich habe
keinen hunger
nein
ich habe
keinen hunger ist deine schwester groß
ist deine schwester groß
nein meiner schwester ist nicht groß
nein meine schwester ist nicht groß ja
meine schwester ist groß
ja meine schwester ist groß
gefällt dir mein neues auto
ja es gefällt mir
es gefällt mir
nein es gefällt mir nicht
was gefällt dir nicht
[Musik]
was gefällt dir nicht mir gefällt die
farbe nicht
mir gefällt die farbe nicht
hast du das gesehen
ist das ein wahl
nein das ist kein wahl
das ist ein delfin
bist du sicher
nein ich bin nicht sicher
vielleicht ist es auch ein haifisch
hast du jemanden kennengelernt
ja ich habe jemanden kennengelernt
nein
ich habe niemanden kennengelernt
hast du im supermarkt etwas gekauft
ja ich habe obst gekauft
nein ich habe nichts gekauft
ich habe nichts gekauft
ich habe meine geldbörse zu hause
vergessen
habe eine neue wohnung
ich habe eine neue wohnung
leider gibt es keinen balkon
das ist schade
gibt es eine terrasse
[Musik]
nein leider gibt es auch keine terrasse
leider gibt es auch keine terrasse
hast du immerhin eine gute aussicht
nein ich habe auch keine gute aussicht
ich habe auch keine gute aussicht
das ist aber traurig
kannst du schwimmen
ja ich kann schwimmen
nein ich kann nicht schwimmen
möchtest du etwas essen
hast du etwas essen
nein danke
ich möchte nichts essen
ja bitte ich habe hunger
hat dich deine mutter angerufen
nein sie hat mich nicht angerufen
sie hat mir auf whatsapp geschrieben
[Musik]
ich heute keinen hunger
ich habe heute keinen hunger
warum
hast du heute schon etwas gegessen
zum frühstück habe ich nur eine banane
gegessen
habe ich nichts mehr gegessen
danach habe ich nichts mehr gegessen
wie findest du meine neue wohnung
gefällt sie dir
naja ich finde sie nicht so ideal
sie hat keinen balkon
sie hat keine balkon
sie hat auch keine garage
da hast du recht
ja da hast du recht
dafür habe ich eine tolle lage
die aussicht ist auch großartig
du warst gestern in einem kurs
[Musik]
hast du dort etwas gelernt
ich habe leider nichts gelernt
ich wusste schon alles von früher
ich würde gern nach wien gehen
warst du schon mal in wien
ja ich war schon in wien
es ist wunderschön dort
nein
ich war leider noch nicht in wien
ich würde dich aber gern begleiten
das ist super
lasst uns doch nach wien gehen
hast du als kind dick
nein ich war nicht dick
ich war als kind sehr dünn
kannst du gut schachspielen
ja ich kann super schachspielen
ich kann gar nicht schach spielen
nein ich kann gar nicht schach spielen
wann kommst du zu mir nach hause
es tut mir leid
ich komme heute leider nicht zu dir nach
hause
warum nicht
ich habe kein auto mehr
eine schwester hat es heute genommen
schwester hat es heute genommen
wie schade
hast du früher in einem restaurant
gearbeitet
nein ich habe in keinem restaurant
ich habe in keinem restaurant gearbeitet
ich habe in einem café gearbeitet
in einem café gearbeitet
wo hast du gearbeitet
ich habe früher in einer schule
gearbeitet
ich habe auch in keinem restaurant
hast du nicht etwas vergessen
nein ich habe nichts vergessen
ich habe alles bei mir
und dein reisepass
habe keinen reisepass dabei
ich habe keinen reisepass dabei
[Musik]
ich reise mit meinem personalausweis
abonniere den kanal der halo deutsch
schule aktiviere das kleine glöckchen
gib uns jetzt ein daumen nach oben
klicke auf diese playlist um weitere
videos zu sehen